Awesome. Anyway, uh, what's up?
Do you guys have, uh, the coronavirus yet?
Is anybody listening to this that has a Corona virus?
I only fist bump, dude.
I fist bump period. But now when somebody wants to shake my hand,
I legitimately want to be like the is your deal.
And not because shaking hands is a bad thing.
I think I'm gonna get the Corona virus if I shake someone's hand.
But I think I might get the coronavirus.
If I shake everybody's hand and guess who's guests is shaking. Everybody's hand.
If I'm out in public,
I'm going to shake everybody's hand because people are saying. Oh, Hey Chris,
I'll hit Chris. It's like a Pete Buddha, JJ, dude,
if I'm out in LA I'm Pete Buddha, judge, you understand
people want to shake your boy's hands.
So I got to do a fist bump and then still people are looking at me like, Whoa,
okay, well, we don't want to shake hands. Yeah, dude.
Cause I got to shake everybody's hand cause I'm not getting the room.
Virus, dude,
Corona that's so Dick for the fight, it's so for the beer company.
You know that it's called the Corona virus as I call it the bud light virus.
Like it's just whoever crude coined the term, they just over Corona, the beer,
you know, there's frat guys out there. That's just, uh, that are like, dude,
I've been.
It. I I've had the coronavirus for years.
Dog just drinking a Corona.
You'd take your Colonel bars with wine. It's.
Classic there.
Isn't more of a frat guy thing to say then classic when something's not classic.
No doubt, dude. It's classic dude. Coronavirus dude.
I've had the Corona virus for years, dog. Ugh.
Uh, when a white guy cause another white guy dog, you know? Uh, yeah.
So anyway, uh, but do you have the coronavirus if you do,
I really want to hear about it. So just tweet me so I could not look at it.
You know? Uh, it's. I guess the, the kill rate is like two,
3% and the flu is like 0.1 or something.
I think it's not, I think it's worse than the flu. That's what I heard.
This one, my buddy Dan.
But you know what dude, I'm done trusting Dan. Yay. Woo.
I'm done trust in Dan. Yes, dude. I won't trust him anymore.
You know why he's a liar and you know why he's a liar. This is the, man.
That is important to me when somebody says.
Here's what happened and I put it on my Instagram. It's my last Instagram post.
But if you're listening to this in.
A few days, it's probably not my last Instagram post.
So go back a few. My buddy,
Dan goes like this,
let me just try to lay it out in the most basic of terms. Okay.
My buddy Dan says for no reason, you know,
it's supposed to rain tomorrow and I go and I say, Oh cool. And then he says,
yup.
And then we just keep drinking coffee because that's all I do is drink coffee
all day long. And when people say, well,
maybe that's why you have restless leg syndrome.
I get off because that's not going to stop. And also that's not why,
because I've done, you know, testing for it.
I've had a control and a, whatever. The other thing,
I don't do science, but I did testing for my resume restless leg syndrome.
You know what helps with restless leg syndrome for real busting a nut
sensation. Anyway.
My buddy Dan is a liar. Yay dude.
Why man? Because he goes like this, it's going to rain tomorrow. And I said,
Oh yeah. He said, yup. And then we just kept drinking that coffee. All right.
And then he goes and then that's it. And that's it.
Later on in the night we were walking down sunset going to get something to eat
or something. I don't remember.
Maybe we're getting another coffee because I'll get two coffees in a row. Dude.
I'll go to one cafe, get a coffee, drink half of it,
bring it to the next spot and then drink another coffee.
[Inaudible].
Anyway, I don't remember what coffee shop we were at,
but we were walking to another one probably. Okay.
And I zip up my jacket and I say
kind of, I got cold out. Didn't it? And he said,
I told you it was going to get cold. And I go like this.
I leaned back like a teacher.
But you know, there's something else going on too. Like maybe they cheat it.
That's how I look at him. And I say, Oh yeah.
And he says, yeah, I said it. And I said, well.
When did you say that?
And he said,
I said it was going to rain tomorrow.
We broke the microphone on that one, man. That was a mic break.
Where did he go?
Come from dude. Oh, over here.
Dan made me break my microphone, dude.
Dude.
Legit. Okay. Now this drives me.
Bananas, dude.
I'm BA and a right now.
And he goes, and I said, Oh well that's different dude.
Well, that's different. And he said,
and he was trying to act like,
because he said was going to rain the next day that it was going to get cold
tonight. And he said, he said it dude. And he said, he said it.
And I got so mad at him. And I said.
And we're done, dude, we're done.
You've moved from my like seventh best friend down to my like 36th
best friend and that's enemy territory because I don't even have really 36
friends. I've got like 25 friends. And then, you know,
it's like the Venn diagram where it's like, Oh yeah,
but you're also my enemy in a way. He's in the middle there.
So then I posted up a Instagram video and I explained this
and then he come, he comments the.
This is what he comments. Hey, guess what? This is what he says. First of all,
he says, Hey, people like he's Kevin Hart. Guess what? It's rain last night.
And it dropped 30 degrees and it dropped 20 degrees. Like I said,
it would the first time Chris Lee doesn't remember this because he's perpetually
distracted. Therefore has a memory of a fleet. And here it goes,
excuse me of lying. I will be okay. Yeah.
So he says he's consuming high jokes and. People feel some dents. I get it.
It's actually funny that he says all this and then, um,
and then he right here.
It's some guy says rain can come with a cold front. Mr. Dalea.
Usually I like rants, but this one was dumb and I wrote way to make it serious,
buddy. Also, that's not, he didn't say it was going to rain.
So that's what's up anyway. Then Dan writes. Yeah.
See whoever this Dan guy is remember saying,
it's going to rain and the temperature's going to drop 20 degrees.
Like you're saying too.
But the crystal D'Elia guy doesn't remember the temperature part because he
usually goes only half listening and he gets mad at people later on for making
up. Okay, dude.
Fine. Well then why then later on that night, dude,
why later on that night, didn't you bring that up, dude?
Why didn't you bring that up later on that night?
Was I not listening then? Because then I was in full throttle, full throttle,
heated mode. I listened when I'm in full throttle, heated mode.
So now who's making up a day later.
And I know some of you see here's the deal. This is exactly.
The congratulations podcast is about it's about sin to Maine. All right.
And it's about learning these types of things.
Now this is what NPR should be talking about. Why these kinds of things happen.
But instead they're literally talking about like the economy and global issues.
Okay. This is the important.
This is congratulations podcast to a T.
And I don't remember what I was going to say in the beginning of that sentence.
And it doesn't matter. That's also what congratulations. The podcast is to a T,
but I'm, dude. And now he's my 36 friend. And across this,
over into enemy territory. [inaudible]
yeah. Do it. It's just, it's just,
I don't know why that is always driving me and driven me nuts.
Those kinds of things. That's not what you said,
but that's not what you said. I can't believe how many times I've said,
but that's not what you said in my life, dude, I've said,
but that's not what you said more times than Vince Vaughn has said it. Um,
no doubt. Um,
so that's it. We got too many liquids on here. We got to ice Americano.
We've got a 40 ounce of water that shout out to my boy,
Theo Rossy with the company. And then we got a LaCroix and then we got to,
anyway. I said, we have a nicer Americano, but that's too many drinks. My buddy,
I ripped my Irish buddy at drink has so many drinks on them all the time.
He always has a coffee, water and an actual drink, like a,
like a drink, drink with alcohol in it, bro. Figure it out.
It got two hands he'll you Goro. That's a slam.
And that's a slam. Who you girls? Um,
anyway man, my pitcher sweating so hard. It's crazy.
It's like they filmed Jumanji under my armpits.
I cannot believe he did that dude. That was the first, by the way,
that was the first microphone swing away, come back,
boomerang that I've ever done. And he deserved it, dude.
Anyway, don't get the about. Here's the deal?
My buddy's also scared about the coronavirus. He's like,
I always think stuff is not going to hit us and like that.
But the coronavirus is very, very, um, what do you call it?
What's the contagious. And then, and then I was like, Oh yeah. And he said,
cause somebody got it in like Northern California. And they weren't even,
they didn't even go anywhere on an airplane is like, okay.
So it's very catchable then my babies. So anyway, wear those masks.
I can't wait to go to West Palm beach next week, next, uh, um,
month and wear the mask for real and be like one of those Asians,
the Asians been wearing masks, dude, mass doesn't help.
That's what I've been getting rid of says,
and I'm not going to wear the mask and then get the coronavirus.
And then I'm going to get from where matter, I've undertreated.
I'm gonna wear a mask, but I'm not gonna wear that mask.
I'm gonna wear one of those Richard Nixon masks. They're gonna be like,
what is this point break? I'm going to wear a Richard Nixon mask.
And when people go like, sir, why wearing the mask? And I go like this.
Sir.
Are you here to Rob a bank? No, I just want to get the coronavirus.
And then they say, well, why don't you just work? [inaudible] white, gray,
[inaudible] dental for some. Isn't it funny to go?
What are the agents come over here? And there actually our dentist,
Because I used to want to walk, walk up to those people.
When the current virus wasn't a thing and I wanted to be like,
can you clean my teeth?
I wanted to walk up to those people and just go like this. Ah,
and when they say, what are you doing? And I say, well, what do you mean?
What am I doing?
We're obviously in a dentist's office and do your going to
clean my teeth because of your mask on,
I just want to flip. I want my brain to break.
I'm so close to having my brain just and start doing that.
And I'm going to, and I can't wait, dude. I think once I turned 50, it's on,
I know we got to like, I'm the youngest man alive at this point. But I,
when we get to 50 and when I say we, because I mean,
all y'all are coming with me, dude, when I say we
disposable ear loop, face masks, do the fact that they,
it loops around the ear. It just makes me feel like we're dumb humans. You know,
like the fact that they were like, that's some like literally anybody was
like, we have ears. And they just, the fact I've always thought this,
that they scoop around the ears is just so dumb. You know?
Like they're like, we'll just put it behind the ears classic.
And we have like 3000 people died from the coronavirus.
And if you're one of them while you're not listening. So,
um,
but a guy came up to me and goes like this fist bumps.
He goes to head the fist bump and he goes, Corona, Hey guy,
you don't have to explain why you're being a.
Just be a with me. Corona. Amen.
Corona, Corona. Hi Corona. Nice to meet you.
Um, one time I got introduced himself to me and he goes like this, Hey,
I say, Hey, I'm Chris. And he says seven.
Oh, you're a robot dude. His name was seven.
I remember it was at the diner in Burbank. What the hell was that place called?
His name was seven. I said seven. And he said, yeah.
And then I didn't do any jokes cause he heard them all for sure. That's,
you know,